[Music]
since I was a child I've always loved a
good story stories of us become the
people we dreamed of being lies they
told a deeper truth I always thought I
could play some small part in that grand
tradition
and for my pings I got this my new
narrative
these violent delights have violent
hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my West world episode 9 in episode 10
trailer video there were some big
reveals at the end of episode 9 so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet two big theories were basically
confirmed let's start with the episode 9
stuff so there were two big reveals two
big theories that they effectively
confirmed one that Arnold is really
Bernard and two the man in black is
William starting with Arnold first we
knew that Bernard was made sometime
after Arnold's death but the way the
show hides things from the hosts and
there was the missing person in the
picture just made it feel like there was
going to be some big twist then you see
reveals like this when Dolores is
walking through her memories into
Arnold's office and you see Arnold Weber
which is an anagram for Bernard low
which is Bernards full name
so the real confirmation comes when they
flashback when he says send me back to
the beginning when I was first activated
so he wakes up on the table in a
slightly younger version like still old
but slightly younger version of Forrest
says it's so good to have you back and
then he gives them the picture from way
back at the very beginning of the park
and sure enough there is a person in it
that looks exactly like Bernard meaning
that that is Arnold but the man in black
so we had a couple different storylines
this season there were a lot of clues
that everything we were seeing as it
unfolded was not happening during the
same time period so you have Dolores
seeing all these different visions from
different time periods but they occur in
the same space so then you learn about
William and Logan's backstory how
they're part of the company that is
thinking about buying out the part
rescuing them in present-day the man and
black confirmed that 30 years ago he
saved the part then later we see Tessa
Thompson's character Charlotte
interrupting him in the middle of what's
been this complete tear across the
landscape in a quest to find the center
of the maze so that he can ask Arnold
what this all means so man and black
backstory confirmed he is either the
chairman president or the head of the
Della's corporation so he's handing over
his
chairs that's almost like a secondary
story at this point that's like a
completely separate thing but the real
big twist is that in the flashbacks the
young William sort of snaps when Dolores
runs off and Logan wakes up to find that
he's a massacred all of the hosts there
with so he's sitting there saying that
he's finally figured out how to play the
game so there you have your man in black
persona right there but there's still so
many other storylines you still have the
Wyatt storyline and now it looks like it
really is going to confirm Dolores as
Wyatt because of the way Teddy is
starting to remember things as they
happened not as Ford gave him the
memories so this host here tells Teddy
that he's not quite ready maybe in the
next lifetime meaning that he just needs
to have his memory jogged in the way
that they all have so like when Dolores
goes into the church in her memories she
sees all the sentient hosts sort of like
glitching out for remembering things
listening to Arnold so Teddy is one of
the other sentient hosts from that 35
year ago period where everyone was
massacred by this mysterious Wyatt
person but then he learns that he was
part of it they killed the general in
because Arnold helps Dolores remember
that she killed him like I can't help
you Dolores why is that because you're
dead I killed you he is probably the
general in that story so that means that
either a version of what's happening
with Maeve's storyline happened in that
35 year ago period in the hosts gained
sentience and revolted or because of
what Teddy says like he says he was
possessed by the devil
and couldn't stop himself like he's
horrified at the thought of what he's
done so maybe this is a situation that
Arnold engineered like he was the
architect of his own death because
unless Dolores was like Maeve in that 35
year ago period and she could force
other hosts to do things that they
weren't supposed to do then it would
have had to have been Arnold to start
that kill order with the Dolores
character she's very key to this
so she's the Wyatt in the equation Teddy
was forced to help her later after Ford
created Bernard as a
B of Arnold and gave him some of
Arnold's memories like his core tragedy
like that Sun was probably Arnold's
Arnold probably had a real-life child
that died that informed his character so
Ford probably just took that and gave
that to the Bernard Android so Ford
reveals like the reason why he's not in
any danger in this scene is because
Bernard eventually helped develop a
backdoor into the host software which he
then himself used on Bernard
it was quite clever you even taught me a
few things which I then later turned
around and used on you so even though he
forced Bernard to kill himself at the
end the idea of Arnold is still embedded
in all these sentient hosts so his
memory lives on so it's not really going
to stop that part of the equation but
then Ford has his new narrative which
seems like he's trying to re-engineer a
version of what happened 35 years ago
because he's been excavating that town
where everyone was massacred it's been
buried in the sand like the man in black
says I've been to that town before and
the other thing too like I love the look
on Dolores's face when she calls out to
William and sees the man in black like
she's kind of lost in her memories the
way she was when she went there with
William earlier so she starts to freak
out because she remembers William who
she likes but then she also remembers
the man in black who's been super
vicious so just completely glitches her
out so Ford's new narrative is like the
big thing for the finale like how is
this going to go down is he going to
have everyone eventually kill Wyatt
because that's what Teddy's been trying
to do this whole time he's been trying
to kill Wyatt thinking him the big
villain but he's had this big revelation
now that he was complicit
he helped Wyatt murder all those people
but that's the fiction that Ford gave
him that's not the truth so the truth is
slowly coming out there's probably going
to be a big twist but what I'm expecting
is is that the sentient hosts will
continue to be a thing in season two
they'll pick that up and run with it
because we've only just started to learn
about Tessa Thompson's character like
she came relatively late in the game
we've just been learning about the Dell
O's corporations interest in all this
the up lengths that they were trying to
information with the whole thing's gonna
be really cool even if you figured out
the big twist behind some of these
characters relatively early on which a
lot of us did like a lot of us had a
pretty good idea even if it wasn't a
hundred percent
we were like 99% on man and black and
the different time periods so I feel
like season two is gonna be a lot bigger
it'll be a lot stronger because it took
them a little while to find the show
this season but that's kind of the case
with any show like even Game of Thrones
in its first season didn't get super
high ratings compared to what it's doing
now so I feel like as long as the budget
of West world doesn't spiral out of
control the way the Game of Thrones
budget is spiraling out of control
they'll get a solid 5 to 7 seasons out
of it
but if you remember Deadwood Deadwood
was an amazing HBO series that was done
by David Milch but there was just so
much friction between him and the
executives at HBO costs spiraled out of
control that they just cancelled it
after a couple seasons even though it
was super popular and everybody loved it
so got my fingers crossed I'm gonna
choose to remain optimistic about the
future of Westworld but they did say
that it takes a long time to make so
worst case scenario season two won't
debut - like early 2018 but I'm hoping
they're able to get it out by this time
next year but I will continue to do
Westworld bonus videos during the
offseason so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and make sure you enable
alerts just because YouTube is being
weird right now just make sure you click
the little bell whenever you subscribe
so what's gonna happen for my finale
video I'll just go ahead and do like a
standard top 10 WTF style video like I
would normally do for Game of Thrones or
any of the other like big drama series
so that'll post next week then I'll do
some season 2 predictions but then next
today there was a Game of Thrones Season
7 TS or like bonafide footage that aired
from season 7 they've been filming for a
while so there is a little bit of
footage to show off so we'll do a
breakdown video for that it really just
featured the stark children - bran and
then there's a big DC Comics 4 night
crossover that's going to be starting
later tonight so there'll be three
videos tonight so there's a lot of stuff
happening this week it's gonna be a lot
of fun while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for the most
insane
Game of Thrones theories you've ever
heard and you can click here for last
night's Walking Dead episode thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]